welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and before the war we have to Siri
has looked at Iron Man's booby-trapped
gauntlets Thor's possible reforged
Mjolnir caps new proto adamantium shield
fortnight approved and Tony's burnt
brain but we have been avoiding perhaps
the most mysterious weapon that had the
most limited screen time an MCU Theo
says double-edged sword and Avengers
endgame a weapon wielded by a weapon
widow whose - gun shows a piece we know
so little about it doesn't even have a
name just double edged sword we got a
name this baby the home wrecker
New Balance should I ever since in-game
came out I probably gotten more
questions about Thanos the sword than
most of the other elements in the film
what is it made of why they ever before
how does it rank in the strength
compared to the other weapons where did
it come from where does it go where does
come from deluso ii after watching gen a
carefully i think i uncovered some major
details about how this sword works
exactly and what that could mean in
terms for the MCU future titles like
Loki Doctor Strange - or darfur mark are
let's start with the swords composition
the sword packs off pieces of Captain
America shield telling us that this
sword must be made of something stronger
than vibranium some fan theories out
there speculated the sword could be made
of adamantium but the filmmakers have
confirmed that vanos got this sword from
a tree in an interview with comic book
calm Joe Russo suggested that Thanos
sadly stored forged in the same process
in which a tree forged the gauntlet for
Thanos nineveh Lear uses the metal guru
for its weapons gurus what Mjolnir
sports from and what Stormbreaker was
forged from so it would imply that
Thanos his sword is made of guru a
substance stronger than the vibranium of
caps shield which would mean yes if the
were wanted to chop the shield into
pieces with Stormbreaker he probably
could have but the reason he only or
didn't break that shield
presumably is that me linear just wasn't
sharpened Motty sword being made out of
a strong otherworldly metal isn't the
most interesting thing about this yond
its rigidity guru has mystical qualities
it can be encoded with magical spells
like Odin's worthiness charm on mule
near
or Stormbreaker possessing the power of
the Bifrost mule near and Stormbreaker
summoned back to their wielders as if
they contain a divine intelligence
connecting them to their possessors
minds
to dr. Strange's cloak of levitation or
yondu's Yakka arrow now again we don't
see much of Thanos his genetic but this
magical component is visible at least
twice if you're watching closely
in one instance Thanos flings the sword
at Thor Thor slides underneath it and
then a super quick shot shows the sword
curving like a boomerang and then
returning back to Thanos's hand now this
wasn't Australian physics here
that's a heavy blade Thanos summoned it
with his mind back to his hand the same
way thornton cap have done with the roof
neil near now the second component is
one many of you noticed Thor uses
lightning to supercharge Iron Man's
armor blast of Thanos who then blocks it
by spinning the sword which yeah the
filmmakers did acknowledge wasn't loose
reference to the goofy Thanos copter
from the comics but then some more
eagle-eyed fans messaged me pointing out
that Thanos doesn't actually spin the
blade with his hand his purple sausage
fingers stay put while the blade on its
own rotates instinctively to protect
Thanos hard to see but the base of each
blade is curved and hooked over a
separate tilt piece rotating
counterclockwise over empty space
briefly until they rejoin with the hilt
piece on the other side how does it stay
greased up while not constantly drifting
into a spin like a fidget spinner magic
we know it's magic because Santos
doesn't make any physical gesture to
start this spin he has no time to react
the blade must be an intuitive extension
of the wielders mind so why is this
important but before we continue thanks
to bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has zero calories yet
it tastes great with over 20 different
flavors to choose from one of those
grape flavors is bankster berry tastes
like every berry you've ever bitten into
but bang flavored a bang that'll wake it
up and start playing 40 chests with
every weapon in them see you check out
Bangla it's the grand you can get 25%
off your order at bang energy calm when
you use the code new rock stars 25 there
you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best bet
self and thanks again to bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy calm using the code in new
rock stars 25 okay the fact that they a
noses magic guru sword functions with
telekinetic summoning abilities actually
reframes it's later moments in the
battle so when Thanos faces Wanda
Maximoff her mystical powers splinter
and break that blade a reminder that her
magic comes from a mystical cosmic place
and she was applying her own kind of hex
to counteract whatever charm Thanos has
on it in this moment and then later when
Captain Marvel drives the iron gauntlet
and Infinity stones toward the open
quantum tunnel in Scott Lang's van
Thanos
shucks his broken sword into that
quantum tunnel and blows it up this
woman is always been curious to me
because what would have happened if the
Avengers were successful in getting the
stones to the tunnel what then like the
plan at this point was to return the
stones back to their original points in
history but that time-travel would have
required Pym particles and all the
quantum technology that they were using
during a time heist
Captain Marvel didn't have any of that
and even if she did how would she know
where to go she didn't join them on the
time high issues and therefore the
brainstorming sessions she would have no
idea where and when to return them it's
almost as if the climactic task of the
biggest movie of all time was kind of
poorly plotted out it's really just
about getting toys for me to be so they
can bloom off each other come on am I
saying of course this was all
intentional because while Captain Marvel
might have been flying blind this mad
tightened was quite familiar with time
travel and with quantum tech since the
filmmakers revealed that he reverse
engineered the Pym particles in order to
time travel from 2014 to the present
they anis knew exactly what he was doing
and exactly what this was in the van and
instead of throwing his broken sword at
Carol he instead throws it into the
quantum tunnel when he winds up that
broke inside of the blade catches the
light in this interesting way like the
whole thing is coated in dust and soot
but the top part of that blade and a few
surfaces on the lower engravings all
illuminate so I don't think this is just
good aim Thanos is once again applying
his mental magical connection to this
weapon to guide it and it wedges in the
machinery it sparks up and then
completely were you looking for that
just got involved a flash of white fills
the screen as the tunnel explodes
blinding us with a shockwave of quantum
energy and we never see the blast crater
the debris of the van or the tunnel or
thanasis sword ever again and forgive me
for sliding into ten boil mode here what
if that quantum blast transported
theosis weapon chaotically through a
quantum wormhole look Pym particles are
keys that give access to the quantum
realm with Tony Stark's RIT's tech
allowing control navigation of it but as
we saw an ant-man the wasp when this
tech malfunctions all bets are off and
all kinds of quantum chaos is suddenly
possible so theoretically we could now
have a deadly blades ipping through time
but not just any blade a blade still
mentally linked to Thanos and as we
learned with Mjolnir during this battle
even win over weapons are outside of
their home timelines whatever spells
they were encoded with remain constant
and so during his final moments with
Thor with cap Captain Marvel Tony Thanos
could happen in his mind guiding old
broken gen'ly back through time for one
final kill I kind of post-credits you to
one of these unruly eight holes in
another timeline
of coming in MCU titles like Loki Doctor
Strange - Thor could all be based in or
around alternate timelines and as we
watched those let's remember that great
- Rick and Morty gravity falls portal
crossover Easter Egg with missing
objects from one moment of one series
sowing into a portal and then popping
out on the other side of another series
and somewhere in an upcoming MCU phase
for event a portal could open and some
poor soul on the other side could find
themselves suddenly impaled with jennae
join the discussion on our official
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram at EA la scala new rock
stars on socials and subscribe to this
channel because who knows the aniseh
sword could surf the multiverse all the
way to the same Raimi's spite of our
movies and we all know how they feel
about broken portals you'll get your
rent when you fix this damn door
[Music]